eurozone finance ministers have decided
to freeze talks on Greece's debt crisis
until after Sunday's vote earlier the
Greek Prime Minister appeared on
national television condemning what he
described as blackmail by creditors and
again he called for the Greeks to vote
no to a bailout extension we spoke
earlier to the journalist Philip
Pangalos in Athens the problem for
Greeks now is that since Monday morning
they've woken up with the banks closed
the banks are going to be closed all
week they can only take out 60 euros a
day from the ATM machines and the real
economy which is already in recession is
just sinking deeper and deeper and this
comes at a terrible time Greece is just
going into the peak of the key holiday
season the tourism season it's the
biggest industry in Greece it accounts
for more than 20 percent of GDP at about
one in five jobs now Greece had
something like 24 million tourists last
year they were looking to 25 million
this year which would have been a record
year and it's one of the few things
still standing up right here now all
this business with the capital controls
and the banks being closed and concern
about the uncertainty is not doing doing
them any good and it's not helping
last-minute bookings now I spoke to the
head of the Greek tourism Federation yes
then he was very concerned about the
damage being done and there is a
campaign to support the yes vote and
accepting the latest austerity measures
in I hope that Greece can still save
itself despite the default from the IMF
on Tuesday night which in reality is
actually there in arrears and there's
still a little bit of time to pull a
rabbit out of a hat and do a deal
problem is that the in the so-called
institutions which is the European
Commission and the ECB the IMF for sort
of frozen outlook picture I don't even
want to talk to the Greeks till after
the referendum and mr. tsipras was
defiant when he addressed the nation on
Wednesday for the third time in a week
again urging Greeks to vote no it's not
clear how this is going
but like the feeling I get with the
banks closed and you know people having
to queue up in 8:00 at ATMs and
pensioners can
up to a maximum of 120 euros of their
pensions people are suffering there's
concern that the economy is sinking and
the guest boat is possibly gathering
momentum on certain times very difficult
for Greeks who initially were numbed and
now I think they're very very worried